CONTEMPT.
-- THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLIN.
OO  "ANGLE."
DEMOCRATS IN THE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE REVEALED THEMSELVES
AGAIN.
IT'S A DEPRESSING SPECTACLE TO
SEE ELECTED OFFICIALS ACTING
LIKE METH DEALERS.
AFTER PUSHING RUSSIAN COLLUSION
FOR 2 YEARS.
THEY WERE FINALLY BUSTED.
NO COLLUSION.
AND NO OBSTRUCTION.
BUT DEMOCRATS REFUSE TO ACCEPT
REALITY AND CONTINUE TO SELL
THEIR POISON TO SCANDAL ADDICTS
ON THE LEFT.
>> THE COLLUSION REPORT OF THE
MUELLER REPORT RECOUNTS THE
CONSTANT INTERACTION OF TRUMP
OPERATIVES WITH RUSSIAN
ADVERSARIES.
>> YOU THINK THERE IS NO
COLLUSION AND NO OBJECTION?
YOU HAVE NOT READ THE MUELLER
REPORT.
>> MR. TRUMP GETS ON THE
TELEPHONE WITH MR. PUTIN AND HAS
A 90 MINUTE CONVERSATION WHERE
HE CAN SEE ON A PHONE CALL HE
SMILED AT HIM.
>> THAT'S YOUR LEADER.
THE COMMANDER-IN CHEAT.
>> Laura: TO KEEP THE HIGH
GOING, DEMOCRATS HOLD OUT BILL
BARR 2 TIME ATTORNEY GENERAL AS
THEIR NEW NEMESIS AND CREATE A
PHONEY CONFLICT ON THE
REDACTIONS IN THE MUELLER REPORT
AND ON BARR'S REFUSAL TO TESTIFY
AGAIN ON THE HILL AFTER THE
DEMOCRATS CHANGED THE RULES FOR
HIS QUESTIONING.
>> THIS IS PART OF A COVER-UP.
>> WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES TO ENGAGE IN,
ONE OF WHICH IS POSSIBLY
IMPEACHMENT.
HOW CAN WE IMPEACH WITHOUT
GETTING THE DOCUMENTS?
I ASK MY COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER
SIDE TO STOP OBSFUICATING.
>> Laura: THAT'S A HARD WORD TO
SAY.
BARR IS NOT LEGALLY ALLOWED TO
RELEASE CERTAIN REDACTED PARTS
OF.
IT THE DEMOCRATS KNOW THIS.
MOST ON THE COMMITTEE ARE
LAWYERS.
MAYBE THEY PASSED A DIFFERENT
TYPE OF BARR EXAM.
BARR BENT OVER BACKWARDS TO
ACCOMMODATE DEMOCRATS BUT NONE
OF THAT MATTERS.
THIS IS ALL THEATRE WRAPPED UP
IN A BOGUS CONCERN ABOUT
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT.
>> THIS OBSTRUCTION MEANS THE
END OF CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT.
>> Laura: I LIKED HIM BETTER
WITH THE CHICKEN.
WHEN HE WAS HOLDING THE CHICKEN.
DEMOCRATS HAVE ALL THEY NEED TO
DO THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
OVERSIGHT.
MUELLER SPENT 2 YEARS AND $30
MILLION PRODUCING THE REPORT.
IF THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO IMPEACH
THE PRESIDENT, THEY SHOULD
CONVENE HEARINGS TOMORROW.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN GIVEN THE
OPTION BY THE DOJ TO READ
EVERYTHING BUT A VERY MINIMALLY
REDACTED COPY OF THE MUELLER
REPORT.
GUESS WHAT?
NONE OF THEM HAVE GONE TO REVIEW
IT OR READ IT AT THE DOJ.
THAT TELLS YOU ALL YOU NEED TO
KNOW.
AFTER WINNING A MAJORITY IN
NOVEMBER, DEMOCRATS PROMISED
RESULTS AND FOCUS.
>> DEMOCRATS PLEDGE A NEW
MAJORITY, OUR FOR THE PEOPLE
AGENDA.
LOWER HEALTHCARE COSTS AND
BIGGER PAYCHECKS AND BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CLEAN UP
CORRUPTION TO MAKE AMERICA WORK
FOR AMERICANS AND NOT SPECIAL
INTERESTS.
>> Laura: WHAT DO THEY HAVE TO
SHOW THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
NOTHING!
>> I THINK IT WAS MAYBE RANKING
MEMBER SAID WE SHOULD BE DOING
LEGISLATION AND HOW MANY
SIGNATURES AND BILLS WERE SIGNED
INTO LAW BY THIS COMMITTEE?
ASK MITCH MCCONNELL WHO DECLARED
THE SENATE IS A GRAVE YARD FOR
ALL LEGISLATION THAT COMES FROM
THE HOUSE.
WE HAVE PASSED OUTSTANDING
LEGISLATION AND IT WENT TO THE
GRAVE YARD.
>> Laura: MORE BLAME SHIFTING
FROM CHICKEN MAN AND MORE
RUSSIAN HYSTERIA.
THEY MAY HAVE VOTED TO HOLD THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN CONTEMPT,
BUT WHAT THEY REALLY DID IT TO
HOLD YOU THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
CONTEMPT.
I THINK MOST WORKING PEOPLE WANT
GOVERNMENT TO FUNCTION PROPERLY
AND STAY OUT OF THEIR LIVES.
IF TWO RECENT POLLS ARE ANY
INDICATION THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE LETTING THE DEMOCRATS KNOW
WHERE THEY STAND.
A CNN POLL SHOWED 56% OF THE
AMERICANS APPROVED THE
PRESIDENT'S HANDLING OF THE
ECONOMY AND A POLL SHOWED TRUMP
IS ENJOYING THE HIGHEST APPROVAL
YET IN THEIR SURVEY AT 46%.
AT THE SAME TIME IN HIS
PRESIDENCY, BARACK OBAMA WAS AT
44% AND HE WON HIS RE-ELECTION.
WHAT IS THE REAL MOTIVATION ON
THE PART OF THE DEMOCRATS?
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN NAILED IT
TODAY.
>> I DON'T THINK TODAY IS ABOUT
GETTING INFORMATION.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ABOUT GETTING
THE UN-REDACTED MUELLER REPORT.
I DON'T THINK LAST WEEK'S
HEARING WAS ABOUT HAVING STAFF
QUESTION THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
IT'S ABOUT DESTROYING BILL BARR
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE NERVOUS HE
WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
THING.
WHAT CAN BE DONE TO A PRESIDENT
CAN BE DONE TO ANY OF US!
THIS COMMITTEE IS SUPPOSED TO
LOOK OUT FOR THAT FUNDAMENTAL
FACT MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
WE ARE NOT DOING THAT TODAY.
>> Laura: EXACTLY RIGHT.
AND GIVEN CONGRESS'S MOST RECENT
APPROVAL NUMBERS, I WOULD SAY